but i gotta ask you about android
and the use of java there because
it's one of the many places where java
just has a huge impact on this world
just on your opinion
is there things that make you happy
uh about the way andro uh java is used
in the android world and are there
things that uh you wish were different
i i don't know how to do a short answer
to that
but i have to do a short answer to that
so you know i'm happy that they did it
um java had been running on cell phones
at that time for quite a few years and
it worked really really well
um there were things about how they did
it
and and in particular um
various ways that they kind of
you know violated all kinds of contracts
the guy who
who led it andy rubin
he crossed a lot of lines there's some
lines crossed
yeah lines were crossed that have since
you know
mushroomed into giant court cases
um and you know they didn't need to do
that
and in fact it would have been so much
cheaper for them to not cross lines
i mean i suppose they didn't anticipate
the the success uh
of this whole endeavor um
or do you think at that time it was
already clear that this is uh it's gonna
blow up
i guess i i i sort of came to believe
that it didn't matter what
andy did it was going to blow up
okay he see he's he you know i kind of
started
to think of him as as as like a
manufacturer of bombs
uh yeah some of the best things in this
world come about through a little bit of
uh
uh explosive well and some of the worst
and some of the worst beautifully put
but is there um
and and like you said i mean does that
make you proud that
the java is in yeah is in
millions i mean it could be billions of
devices and
yeah well i mean it was in in billions
of phones before android came along
um and
you know i'm i'm just as proud as you
know of the way that like
the the smart card standards adopted
java
and they did it they you know everybody
involved in that did a really good job
and that's you know billions and
billions
um that's crazy the sim cards
you know the sim cards in your pocket
yeah i mean
i've been outside of that world for a
decade so
i don't know how that has it has evolved
but um
you know it's just been crazy
you